[Musik]
naja es ist ja kein job es gibt ja auch
kein mensch
gestern als wir eingespielt haben was
eben cool dass so viele junge mädels da
waren mit denen ich dann noch gefragt
habe und ich hoffe dass mir irgendwie
auch eine vorbildfunktion haben für die
und das ist sozusagen wenn die bock
haben eine band zu machen das ist dann
nicht sofort eine girl band ist sondern
das ist vielleicht ja schon so ist das
ist einfach musikerin sind die in der
band spielen und die filmmusik anerkannt
werden für mich hat es dann als ich
angefangen habe musik zu machen
eigentlich gar keine rolle gespielt ich
hab einfach so fans gehört und habe
sofort gedacht so etwas machen es waren
teilweise viele männer es waren aber
auch frauen wie irgendwie des mossad von
the kills und kevin o von den yeah yeahs
oder meg white irgendwie als
schlagzeugerin und dann aber irgendwie
auch ganz viele männer werden irgendwie
hat für mich so geschlechts eigentlich
nie eine große rolle gespielt weil ich
glaube bei musik geht es so umso
universelle themen gibt die zu jedem
sprechen
[Musik]
schreiben sie über sachen die uns
passieren natürlich als frauen aber auch
genauso wie als irgendwie studentinnen
oder als überhaupt menschen die in denen
irgendwie sowas mal passiert ist und ich
glaube manchmal wird das dann so ein
bisschen unnatürlich hoch gebaut weil
sie für uns vielleicht im gegensatz zu
anderen bands wie weiß nicht welches
niveau schranke oder auch für einen
drive oder ist vielleicht eine größere
rolle spielt ja und dann ist manchmal
ein bisschen genervt von den fragen was
lustig ist auch dass alle die das denn
da war dies das erste mal mit kanada
frankreich gespielt haben
und da war es interessant weil diese
viele junge fans haben die dann so total
überrascht waren dass wir die vorband
waren weil die gutachten oder wir bauen
auf der bühne holt das kann ich
eigentlich auch machen sich millionen
fans
wenn man nicht mehr nur gesagt dann kann
man auch nicht görg sagen finde ich oder
ball rock und gehört es ja auch immer so
ein ding dass frauen so schnell girls
sind und männer männer und auch wenn dir
jetzt irgendwie auch schon langsam auf
die 30 zu gewinnen sind wir irgendwie
gehört keine frauen manchmal und ist ja
auch schon fällt es doch ganz schnell
[Musik]